he hoarded bars of gold and now
Democrats are leaving him cold New
Jersey Senator Bob Menendez in court for
the first time and pleading not guilty
to Federal bribery charges the feds say
this sleazy Senator traded political
favors in exchange for wads of cash
Mercedes-Benz and bars of gold at least
30 Senate Democrats are calling on him
to reside but it sounds like Bobby ain't
going anywhere
why aren't you resigning
why won't you resign sir Senator because
I'm innocent what wrong with you guys
yeah
dirty Bob may not be the only bribe
loving Democrat in Town House
Republicans say hunter Biden was wired
250 Grand from China back in 2019
enlisted Joe Biden's Wilmington home as
the beneficiary address judge you are
aching to respond yes yes I am very
upset with the Senate Democrats they are
not giving uh gold bar Bob Menendez the
presumption of innocence to which he is
inspired this man deserves to keep his
seat the public will decide whether he
should leave and let me tell you why the
Cuba defense is a good defense okay
first of all the evidence may seem
overwhelming but I caution these
Democrat Senators the truth is that the
United States Supreme Court is very open
to defense arguments when it comes to
the issue of corruption and public
officials we know that from Jack Smith's
last prosecution of Governor McDonald
from Virginia the truth is there's got
to be a quid and a quote okay we got the
quit we got the gold bars we've got the
cash we've got all that evidence but
what is the quote the United States
Supreme Court has said that the pro must
be a formal exercise of government power
calling up someone is not a formal
exercise of government power you know
just saying listen do my friend of favor
is not a formal exercise of government
power so the Reason by the way that
these Democrats who are willing to let
criminals out with no bail but want this
Senator out of the Senate is because the
Senate is so close and they're afraid
he's going to lose the truth is that the
New Jersey Democrats the last time he
was indicted they wanted him to stay
that's because the difference was so big
his remaining there wouldn't make a darn
but a difference but I want you to think
about one thing they've got fingerprints
on gold bars they've got fingerprints on
envelopes they've got all kinds of
evidence they quit we don't have the
quote but they couldn't get fingerprints
off a glass scene bag with cocaine in it
in the white house it's just a question
of who they want you know Martha this
story this Hunter Biden story The 250
bribe sent to 250 000 bribe sent to
Joe's house this is not a Smoking Gun as
CNN used to say every day about Russia
inclusion this is a bona fide neutron
bomb but again it's not the journalists
who chased this story on the contrary
they tried to bury this story this is a
story that had to come out through
Republicans because they're too busy
saying there's no evidence there's no
evidence don't you know there's no
evidence it's like shut up for two
seconds and let's look at this story
let's see if there's something behind it
because that's what we do you know this
is a quarter of a million dollars that
went from this Chinese company that is
very closely connected to the Chinese
government and the money went to Hunter
Biden and he put as his ad address the
Biden home in Delaware okay so this is
money that showed up at then candidate
for President Joe Biden's home at that
time he's running for president
meanwhile he's turning around and saying
you know I have known anything about my
husband my about my son's business
dealings
um China he's scoffed during the debate
that we don't have any connection to
China we're not getting any money from
China now Abby Lowell came out and said
essentially that
he came out and said that this was a
loan that was given from BHA or b-h-o I
think the company is called
um that it was a loan and that the only
reason that he gave that address at the
Biden home was because it was the only
permanent address that he had at that
time however Hunter Biden had a
California address which was on a number
of these documents so he did have
another address but it went to Dad's
house just go back one more time to the
email which is I think the Touchstone of
this whole story which is Hunter Biden
saying I hope you know you don't have to
I won't ask you to give me 50 when you
support when you have to pay for
everything for this whole family Jesse
where are all the chuckleheads that
chase the fandoms of Russian collusion
and this is the biggest this is the
biggest story you have a president when
he was running getting 250 Grand from
China sent to his house how is that not
like he's he's got to go to jail Greg
lock him up Greg China is not bribing
the bidens they are just loaning the
bidens money come on man it's just like
if after Trump announced he was running
for president he comes down the golden
escalator and all of a sudden the
Russians loan the Don Jr quarter million
dollars and then happened to use Trump
Tower as the address for the wire that's
not suspicious at all I love this line
from the new stuff that just came out
Hunter even referred to access to his
father as the keys to my family's only
asset
oh my God this is good and even more how
about this how about Joe Biden hosts two
Mexican billionaires at his house in
Washington D.C and then flies his son to
Mexico City and they come back with a
bag of cash what is that called what is
that called it's called corruption you
know Jessica last word to you feel free
to make it about me
I really liked your read thank you for
that because it was a long read and
sometimes I struggle with those things
okay
um I think that we all know how wire
transactions work so when you fill out
the information of who you're wiring it
to you don't write uh big guy's house
Wilmington Delaware you put in your
account numbers right it goes to Hunter
Biden's account
and James Comer knows this he also knows
that Hunter Biden's personal account
which was with Wells Fargo had been
registered in Wilmington Delaware he by
the way moved back in with his parents
as many grown men do when they get
divorced in 2017. so not only did he
have his bank account registered there
he had his personal credit card his
Apple account and his driver's license
was looking bride with the son of the
presidential candidate that's fine first
of all this this is going on that entire
period when Joe Biden was not a
candidate it was 2019 he had already
announced yeah I actually checked the
dates
the money went to Hunter Biden when you
have the money going to Joe Biden then
you're going to have problems you can
bribe the family members and James Comer
again is misrepresenting this case
completely to the American public
because he wrote a letter to the White
House in January making it clear that he
knew that Hunter Biden's home address
during this period was in Delaware and I
would add that Republicans are going to
continue embarrassing themselves like
the latest one Congressman Jason Smith I
think he's from Missouri this afternoon
was giving a press conference where he
laid out a timeline that of course was
completely false and an NBC reporter
held his feet to the fire about it and
then he had to finally back down after
he sputtered all over himself and admit
that he's not a timeline expert you
can't have an impeachment and not be a
timeline expert and you can't have an
impeachment based on why did that for
twice you got to move on Jessica I'm not
I don't want to cut you off I am the way
I do so annoying yeah up next Joe
Biden's dog chomping down on another
secret service agent hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else